takes 10 to 15 years to develop diabetes
and it's reversible like your condition
is reversible but it's not going to
happen overnight working out is
essential for entrepreneurs for human
beings like I know when I'm consistently
strength training like I did this
morning I did some dead lips and some
squats front squats back squats I feel
so much better than if I go a week
without working out cuz I'm traveling I
just start to feel a little cruddy yeah
so getting into a consistent routine is
so important for all human beings and
finding what that sweet spot is I used
to think it needs to be a 60-minute
crossfit workout now it's 30 minutes in
and out like very efficient and that
works for me combine that with
basketball I'm good to go